yes I think perhaps not as high as some
people had anticipated I think some
people and including me thought he might
get something like 35 years but maybe 30
essentially doesn't make a great deal of
of difference at this stage
um she said at one point the judge that
she was giving him a 20 percent
reduction for his guilty pleas
um although she talked about his shame
rather than his remorse she didn't pull
her punches she said that he'd had a
spectacular downfall for a man charged
with upholding the law and empowered to
do so even to the extent of being
authorized to carry carry a gun and that
really was one of the main themes of her
sentencing remarks that he had abused
his power as a police officer to entice
reassure or intimidate his victims and I
think that was always going to be the
case although
officers police officers are often given
compounded sentences where they commit
crimes on duty none of his crimes were
committed on duty but very clearly and
obviously to the judge he used his
status as a police officer to help him
commit those crimes and we heard from a
number of victims didn't we yesterday
who said that they were encouraged to
meet him because he was a police officer
telling some of them that they would be
safe with him because he was a police
officer and then threatening them within
one case a gun perhaps it was a replica
gun nobody can be sure but um showing
his warrant card to others and then to
many of his victims telling them that
because he was a police officer if they
ever did complain to the authorities
about his attacks on them their word
would not be believed over his
and Martin we're expecting to hear from
the police and also the crown
prosecution service
foreign
yes we're going to hear I think
immediately here from the officers who
investigated finally investigated uh
Carrick now these are officers from the
Hertfordshire police force who worked
also with bedfordshire and
Cambridgeshire police forces and those
three were involved because the victims
largely came from that part of the world
but um we're probably going to hear from
the senior officer involved in the
investigation I don't know that we're
going to hear from the Metropolitan
Police at this stage they weren't
involved directly in the investigation
and we did hear from from them yesterday
another in a long line of apologies from
the Metropolitan Police for allowing
Carrick to to continue in his job even
when they did know that he had at least
been accused of predatory behavior over
many years so yes we'll hear from the
detective involved in this prosecution
of Carrick and we'll also hear from the
crown prosecution service which of
course played a big part in the
formulating of the charges to which
Carrick eventually was persuaded to
plead guilty persuaded by the the wealth
of evidence against him the numbers of
victims who had complained about him and
a very obvious pattern of behavior over
many years in which ultimately he was
convinced that he couldn't argue as he
had originally on his arrest that he
either couldn't remember those crimes
all those attacks or
um he had only ever had sex with any of
those women by their consent
Martin
it's clear I I felt sort of simmering
anger but behind what a lot of what the
judge was saying where she talked about
why some of the women had not come
forward how they felt that they wouldn't
be believed she said it spoke to the
moral Corruption of the way that victims
are treated in society and and the fact
that that he had used his position was
clearly an aggravating Factor here
foreign
influence
um I didn't quite catch everything she
said but she talked about how that stood
in the way of the revolution of women's
dignity so
I'm sure we would have heard something
similar from a male judge but perhaps
there's an added poignancy that we were
hearing those words from a woman judge I
mean she was very um very calm and
collected in her delivery as you would
expect from a judge but yes I think
perhaps we could we could read
behind that that she did have an awful
lot of sympathy and empathy with with
those women
victims from whom she had heard if not
directly and she'd heard their Victim
Impact statements yesterday when they
went into
Dreadful detail about how they had lived
in fear they had suffered great physical
pain
but also they've been intimidated
by Carrick into not reporting what he
had done to them and then subsequently
had gone on to suffer in their own
relationships uh their lives their
mental health had been damaged and
particularly one victim I spoke to
yesterday a fellow police officer of
David Carrick who said that she had
lived ever since
2004 after he raped her with her guilt
for not reporting him at the time but
said look you know maybe I had a greater
responsibility report to report him I
was a police officer but I'm also a
human being
and Martin we can hear like loud voices
behind you there are a lot of people who
are very angry about this case aren't
there and a lot of people down there
protesting against violence against
women
yes this is a protest group that was
here yesterday uh been here today since
um since about nine o'clock since since
before the um the hearing started
essentially making their voices uh heard
about the issue the whole issue of male
violence and holding this case up as a
shining example of how men do go
undetected uh in when they are
committing crimes against women I mean
of course many are are caught and
convicted but they're holding up the
case of David Carrick as somebody who
was allowed to commit many offenses many
terrible crimes against women even
though some of those offenses were
reported there was a gathering of
intelligence around this man who
was a police officer as well a man as
the judge said empowered to hold up the
law in spite of all that he was allowed
to continue for more than 20 years
serving as a police officer